- All right, let's wind things down
with something simply
beautiful and inspirational
from the pages of social media.
This is What I'm Liking.
(upbeat music)
(audience cheering)
You may know
that I'm a bit obsessed with
all things under the sea.
So I love what one scientist is doing
to give us lay people a
glimpse of the delicate lives
of turtles living in our oceans.
He temporarily mounts
cameras to turtle shells
as they swim, interact,
and eat beneath the water.
Not only does it produce stunning visuals.
I love this video so much, it's so happy.
It reinforces just how
delicate marine life is
and how simple it is
for us to do our part
to protect ocean life.
From the Turtle Camera Project,
everybody say hello to
Dr. Nathan Robinson!
(audience cheering and applauding)
- Hi, everyone. Hi, Kelly.
- Hello, Dr. Robinson!
This is so beautiful.
I just love the footage so much.
It makes you so happy.
It's so good.
So how did you come up with this idea?
- Oh, well, it all
started several years ago.
I was working on a research
vessel in Costa Rica
and I discovered a sea turtle
that had a something led
wedged inside its nostril.
And when I grabbed and
I jumped into action.
Grabbed my (indistinct) I
have to pull out the object,
I discovered that it was a plastic straw.
In fact, it was this plastic straw.
When that video was uploaded online,
immediately went viral.
And engaged with millions
of people worldwide
about the issue that single use plastics
are having on our oceans.
And seeing that impact
filled me with inspiration
to start wondering what
other videos I could produce
to help engaging with
ever larger audiences
about ocean conservation.
And one of my next big projects
was the Turtle Cam Project.
- I love this.
So how do the cameras work?
Like what have you learned?
- So this is a Turtle Cam.
It's a dive camera.
And we temporarily mount
onto a sea turtle shell
using these metal links
that corroded after about
three to four hours.
So when the corrode,
the camera pops off,
we're able to find the camera
again using this antenna.
And that's where we
recover the footage inside.
And that footage gives
us wonderful insights
into where sea turtles living,
what they're feeding on.
But it's also given us
some amazing insights
into their social lives.
But the most important
thing that we've learned
through all of these videos,
is the impact that each one of
us can have on ocean health.
Simple decisions,
reducing your CO2 output,
reducing the amount of
plastic you consume.
These are the little steps
that we can make wherever
we live in the world
to make our oceans a
healthier place for ourselves
and all the animals that live there.
- Yeah, absolutely.
Well, thank you so much, Nathan.
I'm liking your posts right now.
Well, that's not all.
Our season long partner pilot pin,
Makers of Friction,
the go to erasable pin of
the Kelly Clarkson Show
want to celebrate those creating
and inspiring fearlessly
just like you, sir.
So they're gonna give
you a thousand dollars.
Maybe buy more cameras.
(audience cheering)
(Kelly chuckling)
- That is, oh my God, that's amazing.
Thank you so much.
- Absolutely.
(inaudible)
- Such an incredible gesture.
That will go to help protect
sea turtles worldwide.
- Ah man, keep going what you're doing.
We love it and we supporting it.
So keep what you're doing Dr. Robinson.
Thank you so much for joining us.
(audience cheering)
Thank you to all our guests this hour.
Kristen Bell, (inaudible), Candace Nelson,
Panic at the Disco.
Y'all have a great day.
And if it's not well, trying to.